[موسيقى]
في تحدي امنيا جديد تقود قوات حرس الحدود
ومسؤول جمارك في الاردن ودول الخليج حربا
شرسه ضد شبكات تهريب المخدرات اذ لا يمر
يومه دون الاعلان عن ضبط شحنات كبيره من
المواد المخدره وخاصه الكبتاجون وكلما
اشتدت المراقبه عبر منافذ البريه او
البحريه زاد المهربون وسائل التمويه
والاخفاء حرصا على تدفق العائدات الضخمه
التي تدرها عليهم هذه المواد السامه ورغم
ان عمليه التهريب لا تزال تركز على منطقه
الخليج الا ان مسؤولين وخبراء دق ناقوس
الخطر محذرين من خطط مهربي الكبتاجون
لاستهداف اسواق جديده من بينها الاسواق
الاوروبيه والامريكيه فكيف تتنامى عمليات
التهريب رغم كل الاجراءات المبذوله
لمكافحتها والى اي حد قد ينجح التحالف
الدولي الجديد بقياده امريكا في تضييق
الخناق على الاطراف المستفيده من اموال
المخدرات اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم تشهد المناطق الحدوديه بين
سوريا والاردن تصاعدا لعمليه تهريب
المخدرات بكل انواعها وخاصه منها اقراص
التي باتت تهدد امن الاردن ودول الخليج
بشكل خاص لمعرفه الخيارات التي تفرضها هذه
التحديات على هذه الدول والمساعي
الاقليميه والدوليه لتكثيف التنسيق
والتعاون من اجل مواجهه التوسع في عمليات
انتاجي وتهريب المخدرات يسعدنا ان يكون
معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستوديو
السيد سميح المعايطه وزير الاعلام
الاردنيه السابق من الرياض السيد سالم
اليامي المستشار السابق في وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه ومن واشنطن السيد اندرو تابلور
كبير الباحثين في معهد واشنطن لسياسات
الشرق الادنى والمختص في الشؤون السوريه
فاهلا بهم جميعا
رغم كل الجهود المبذوله للحد من تدفق
المخدرات عبر المنافذ البريه والبحريه
وحتى الجويه لا تزال محاولات تهريب
المخدرات من سوريا الى الاردن متواصله
ووفقا لتقرير نشره معهد نيولاينز الامريكي
فان تجاره حبوب الكبتاجون المخدره توسعت
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط بشكل كبير خلال عام
2021 حتى تجاوزت قيمتها خمسه مليار دولار
واكد التقرير ان النظام السوري يستخدم هذه
التجاره كوسيله للبقاء سياسيا واقتصاديا
اثر العقوبات المفروضه عليه رغم نفه
المستمر لاي علاقه له بتصنيع او تصدير هذه
الحبوب
[موسيقى]
تحت عنوان تهديد الكبتاجون لمحه عن
التجاره غير المشروعه والاستهلاك والواقع
الاقليمي اشار تقرير معهد نيولايز الى ان
تجاره الكبتاجون باتت تشكل اقتصادا غير
مشروع سريع النمو في الشرق الاوسط ومنطقه
البحر الابيض المتوسط وفي حين ان منطقه
الخليج لا تزال الوجهه الرئيسيه يوضح
التقرير ان شمال افريقيا وجنوب اوروبا قد
تم استهدافهما ايضا من قبل التجار
الكبتاجون ويشير التقرير الى تورط افراد
من عائله الرئيس بشار الاسد وكبار اركان
نظامه وحزب الله اللبناني في تصنيع
الكبتاجون وتهريبه واستخدام التجاره وسيله
للصمود سياسيا واقتصاديا في وجه العقوبات
الدوليه واستنادا الى احتساب قيمه مضبوطات
كبيره فان القيمه المحتمله لتجاره
الكبتاجون عام 2021 قدرت باكثر من خمسه
مليارات وسبعمائه مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
شحنه من الشاي موجهه للتصدير انطلقت من
مرفا بيروت
سرعان ما اكتشفت الشرطه اللبنانيه انها
مجرد غطاء لتجاره ممنوعه كمان ضبط شحنه
كابتاجون كانت
بطريقه
لافريقيا لتوجو ومن بعدين بعد ما تتبدل
وتتغير وراها تروح
لمحل بالخليج هذه واحده من حالات كثيره
اضحت هاجسا لدى دول جوار سوريا وعاملا
يعقد العلاقات مع دول خليجيه فالتجاره
مخدر الكبتاجون اخذه في التوسع انطلاقا من
مصدرها الرئيسي سوريا رصد الجيش الاردني
اكثر من 160 شبكه في سوريا تعمل على تهريب
هذه المخ لدول الجوار
وطور تجار الكبتاجون اساليبهم في نقلها
فاستعمل الطائرات المسيره خلال العام
الجاري وحده رصد الجيش الاردني سبع مسيرات
اجتازت الحدود الاردنيه قادمه من سوريا
وتنوعت حمولتها بين اسلحه ومخدرات
انها جبهه تعلم السلطات الاردنيه انها
تتطلب منها خيارات دفاعيه فعاله لمجابهه
الخطر القادم من وراء الحدود في اذار مارس
الماضي طلب العهد الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني من وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الذي كان يتفقد قوات امريكيه في الاردن
طلب مساعده بلاده في حربها على المخدرات
على المستوى الرسمي تقول عمان ان
الميليشيات المدعومه من ايران هي المسؤوله
عن عمليات التهريب لكن وقوف النظام السوري
وراء هذه التجاره في حكم المؤكد وفق
مراقبين
يعتقد انه نمط من الابتزاز السياسي يمارسه
النظام ليكون رساله سياسيه تستجدي وقف
عقوبات قيصر المفروضه عليه امريكيا
والمساعده في اعمار سوريا في 23 يوليو
تموز الماضي عقد اجتماع امني اردني سوري
وصف بالاول من نوعه في عمان شارك فيه قائد
الجيش الاردني ووزير الدفاع السوري ورؤساء
استخبارات البلدين لكن نتائجه وفق وسائل
اعلام امريكيه اكدت ان النظام في سوريا لا
يفعل ما يكفي لمحاربه المخدرات ولم يفي
بتعهدته للدول العربيه وفق مبادره خطوه
مقابل خطوه لتطبيع العلاقات معه
حسب تحليل لموقع هيللا الامريكي من
المستبعد ان يوقف النظام السوري وانتاج
المخدرات وتصديرها لانها تمثل شريانا
حيويا له ومصدر دخل مهمه وهو ما يتطلب من
الولايات المتحده اخذ دورها في هذه
المعركه حسب الموقع لكن باي طريقه
هذا اجتماع على المستوى الوزاري نظمته
الولايات المتحده في السابع يوليو تموز
الماضي لاطلاق تحالف دولي للتصدي لتهديدات
المخدرات المصنعه وعلى راسها الكبتاجون لا
ترافق هذا الجهد الدبلوماسيه اي تحركات
عمليه امريكيه على الارض رغم وجود قوات
امريكيه في سوريا حيث مصدر هذه المخدرات
الاول
يعتقد ان للولايات المتحده قدره على
المساهمه بضربات استباقيه واستخباراتيه ضد
مصدري الكبتاجون قبل وصوله الى دول الجوار
وفي مقدمتها الاردن لكن قراءات تذهب الى
انها لن تفتح جبهه جديده بتوجيه ضربه
عسكريه مباشره بسبب تعقيدات الحاله
السوريه والادوار الايرانيه هناك
ربما يراهن الاردن على مساهمه امريكيه
اكثر فاعليه بتزويده بمعدات متطوره للكشف
المبكر عن شبكات التهريب وادواتها
سيد سميح المعايطه اهلا وسهلا بك الى اي
مدى الكبتاجون الان يشكل هاجسا كبيرا
بالنسبه للاردن وهو يتدفق عليه بهذا الشكل
من سوريا يعني هي احلى بنسميها حرب حرب
المخدرات والمتفجرات لانه التهريب قاعد
بشمل ايضا انتهى محاولات تهريب بطائرات
مسيره الى مواد متفجر يعني اخر واحده
طائره مسيره قبل فتره بسيطه كان فيها تي
ان تي يقبلها كان في اسلحه وهيك يعني احنا
هاجس كبير جدا لانه سوريا موضوع الكبتايون
صار اقتصاد وليس حاله تهريب يعني حالات
تهريب طول عمرها موجوده بين الدول في
المناطق الحدوديه سواء بضائع او اغنام هاي
كان موجود او محاولات سلاح بسيط فردي او
مخدرات الى اخره لكن اليوم بصير هذا
اقتصاد الكبتاجون والاقتصاد يعني حتى ليس
فقط من الاردن حتى اللاذقيه في محاولات
تهريب عبر سنوات الاخيره من 2020
وجاي الى اوروبا بشكل كبير والاخطر من هيك
انه احنا بنشوف
التوثيق اللي كان بيوثقه الجيش الاردني
لمحاولات التهريب اللي بتم ضبطها عبر
التصوير التصوير الليلي والمعدات الموجوده
على الحدود بعض بعض محاولات التهريب بكون
مع المحاوله 200 250 مسلح بحمل العمليه
فهي قصه لها علاقه بمليشيات لها علاقه
بتواطؤ جزء من النظام السوري الى علاقه
بالتواضع قوات مسلحه سوريا تجار يعني
مخدرات ففي شبكه بالقصه وراء الموضوع
وانتجت هذا الاقتصاد اللي هو بعمل بهذه
المليارات اليوم بنتج لما تفضل حضرتك
للنظام السوري وبنتج للتجار وبنتج
للمليشيات وفي نفس الوقت كل فتره بالتصنيع
طريقه طرق التصنيع المواد الاماكن اللي
تصنيع الكبتاجون ما لا يحتاج الى مصانع
ولا يحتاج الى شيء فمن السائل انتاجه
ومردود عالي جدا داخل تدخل سوريا في شكوى
من من انتشاره ومردوده ويستخدم سياسيا من
بعض الميليشيات اللي موجوده على في مناطق
الجنوب السوري ضد الاردن فهي حاله مقلقه
لكن احنا بالنسبه لنا الجيش الاردني يقوم
بضبط الحدود ما يتعلق بالحدود الاردنيه
بشكل كامل وغير قواعد الاشتباك يعني انت
لما بكون في تهريب
بالتوقف الى اخره اليوم كل من يعني يتعدل
حدود او يقترب من الحدود من داخل الاراضي
السوريه يتم اطلاق النار على النار عليه
مباشره وهذا في نوع من الردع اكثر فهي قصه
مقلقه صحيح لكن
هناك اشاره في تقارير متعدده الى تورط
كامل للنظام زائد ميليشيات التابعه للحرس
الثوري
تابعه بعضها الى حزب الله بالتالي تعقد
المشهد بهذا الشكل هل يعقد المهمه اكثر
بالنسبه للسلطات الاردنيه يعني احنا بتعرف
عنا الازمه من 2011 وكان قبلها العراق
الجيش الاردني في حاله يعني خلينا نقول
تحفظ من اكثر من عشره سنه لكن هذا الامر
اضاف عبء لانه احنا بدنا نضره كمان ليش
بقول لك يا حرب الايرانيين فشلوا باختراق
الساحه الاردنيه بانشاء مخالب بينهم تنظيم
ميليشيا مجموعه تابعه لهم
يعني موضوع المخدرات والمتفجرات والاسلحه
اللي بحاولوا يهربوها بالمسيرات او على
الارض هي محاولات لمناكفه الاردن او
محاولات الى طابع سياسي في جانب يعني احنا
بندرك تماما هذه الحرب لها طابع سياسي من
الجانب الايراني في محاوله اختراق الساحه
الاردنيه او اغلاق الاردن او انه ايران
تمتلك ورقه للتفاوض مع الاردن لانه كان في
مفاوضات في بغداد بين الاردن وايران
والايرانيين كانوا يتعاملوا بنوع من خلينا
نقول تضييع الوقت دون الوصول الى شيء
وزائد الخطوره بموضوع المخدرات والكبتاجون
على الاردن وعلى اخواننا بالخليج الاردن
حكى مع القياده الس بشكل واضح ونحكم فيها
حتى مع الرئيس السوري بشكل واضح وكان في
جلسات ايضا بين المسؤولين امنيين من
الاردن وسوريا
المخابرات رئيس الاركان وبعديها بيان كان
في محاولات اجتماعا بالقاهره قبل فتره
لموضوع المبادره وبيان عمان قبله وبعده
كان في محاولات شيء مخدرات وشي متفجرات
واضح ان السوريين مستفيدين جدا من الموضوع
وزائد انه لا يستطيعوا ضبط الايقاع
الميليشيات وقدرتها ونفوذها والرشوه
والاستفاده من الفرقه الرابعه اللي تتبع
ماهر الاسد واضح والجهات الموجوده هناك
صار في حجم مصلحه حجم يعني خلينا نقول
شبكه من المصالح موجوده ما بين الميليشيات
والنظام وما بين تجار وما بين خليط ذاك
انا بسميه بقول لحضرتك اسمه اقتصاد
الكبتاجون لانه صار يجيب لسوريا ما لا
تستطيع الحصول عليه لا من تصدير ولا من
مساعدات وايضا بالعمله الصعبه بالدولار
وايضا من اكثر المتضررين دول الخليج
والسعوديه ربما تحديدا السيد سالم اليامي
الضرر اللاحق الان بالمملكه والمنطقه
عموما
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم احييك استاذ محمد
احيي السيدات الساده المشاهدين احيي ضيوفك
الكرام انا سعيد بانضمامي الى برنامجك
المفضل في الحقيقه يعني القصه التي يعني
تفضل سعاده الاستاذ سميح
بعرضها هي تقريبا تقرا لابواب وتقلق
المسؤولين في المنطقه الخليجيه وفي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه سؤالك عن حجمها
حجمها في الحقيقه ضخم وضخم جدا ولا يمر
اسبوع الا ويكون هناك ضبطيه او ضبطتين او
اكثر المشكله استاذ محمد يعني هي ان
المملكه ادركت حقيقه وكذلك شقيقات
الخليجيات ان الموضوع ليس موضوع حمايه
داخليه او ليس تكثيف لجهود الضبط رغم ان
هذه الجهود متواصله لسبب بسيط جدا وهو ان
المصدر معروف هذا رقم واحد الشيء الاخر
انه تم الحديث مع المصدر والتزم في بعض
كما تقول تقارير رصينه انه خلال شهر واحد
من بعد المصالحه او تاهيل النظام لعودته
الى الجامعه العربيه سيكون هناك يعني
قوائم مفصله بالمنتجين وبالمصانع المصدرين
وبطرق التصدير لكن بعد فتره وربما تابعتم
قبل اسابيع قليله قبل اسبوعين او عشره
ايام تقريبا كان هناك لقاء لقياده القياده
السوريه وتحدث عن هذه الجزئيه بالذات وقال
ان من اتوا بالارهاب الى سوريا هم من اتوب
بالمخدرات وهذا تنص الجديد في الحقيقه من
الجانب السوري الرسمي الذي التزم في اكثر
من مره على مستوى القياده وعلى مستوى
وزاره الخارجيه او وزير الخارجيه السوري
بان يكون هناك وقف القراءه التي تقول ان
عدم قدره النظام السوري على ذلك هو يعني
هي المتواليه التي تقول ضعيف السياده هو
ضعيف السي لذلك لا يسيطر الشيء الاخر يؤكد
ان هناك فاعلين على الارض السوريه سواء
كانوا من المقربين من النظام او من قوى
عسكريه مدربه او حتى من ميليشيات او القوه
التي تحكم او يعني تساعد النظام في
استمراره على البقاء لذلك النظام في تقدير
اعتقد انه فقد ورقه الكبتاجون التي يعني
قام بها في الحقيقه في علاقاته وفي عودته
للمنظومه العربيه على الاقل الى الان قد
يكون هناك شيء في المستقبل لا نعرف لكن
الى الان هناك فشل ذريع في ايقاف هذه
السموم التي تشكل حربا يعني توصف في منطقه
الخليج بانها حرب وتهدد امن وسلامه
المجتمع وتهدد امن وسلامه الناس في
المنطقه رغم ان سيد اليامي رغم ان دول
الخليج وهي تحاول ان تطبع العلاقه مع نظام
بشار الاسد اعتمدت سياسه الخطوه خطوه
بمعنى نحاول ان نتقدم في التطبيع معك كلما
تقدمت انت ليس فقط في الحل السياسي وانما
ايضا في مكافحه المخدرات ولكن يبدو ان
سياسه الخطوه خطوه هذه لم تنجح الى حد
الان على الاقل
انا من وجهه نظري كان هناك ثلاث عوامل
رئيسيه للتقارب او لتاهيل الجانب السوري
للعوده الى يعني الحاضنه العربيه والى
الجامعه العربيه الموضوع الاول وهو الاهم
في تقديري وهذا ربما يتفق عليها اكثر من
باحث واكثر من مراقب هو وقف تصدير
الكبتاجون الى الدول العربيه بشكل خاص هذا
رقم واحد الشيء الثاني كان هناك حديث عن
عوده اللاجئين الشيء الثالث كان هناك حديث
عن عمليه اعمار وربما يعني في شكل من
الاشكال تعويضات للجانب السوري او
استثمارات من الجوانب من الدول العربيه
هذه هي المسارات الثلاثه الخطوه الاولى في
تقديري فشل فيها الجانب السوري بمعنى لم
يحقق شيء كانت تصريحاته في الحقيقه قبل
مده قصيره يعني عبر شاشه تلفزيونيه
اخباريه معروفه يعني كانت صادمه في
الحقيقه وكانت تعلن ان فشل سياسه الخطوه
مقابل خطوه
نعم الامر لم لم يتوقف عند الاردن او دول
الخليج سيد اندرو تابلور هناك الان تخوفات
من ان يصل الكبتاجون الى اوروبا وامريكا
ليس فقط تخوفات وانما ايضا وقائع ما حجم
الخطر المتوقع او الموجود حاليا
الانتاج في سوريا كما تعلمون لا تكلف
كثيرا وهذه المخدرات تجد طريقها الى دول
الخليج كما تفضل ضيوفكم ولكن ايضا في
مناطق اخرى في شمال سوريا وحتى خارج سوريا
وهذا ايضا ينقلها الى اماكن اخرى نتحدث عن
مشكل الدوله ليس موجودا في الشوارع الان
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لدينا
مشاكل اخرى مرتبطه بالمخدرات في امريكا
لكن هذا يبقى جزء من المشكله الموجوده
هناك لان هذه الشبكات هي الشبكات دوليه
وعالميه مرتبطه مع بعضها البعض وهذه هي
الشبكات التي تمول من قبل نظام الاسد ايضا
تشكل خطر بالنسبه لامريكا ولحلافه وهذا
خطر داهم قائم لا يمكن ان نت عنها اذن هذا
يجعل من الصعوبه مكان التعامل مع هذا
الموضوع وينبغي القول بالنظام الاسد متورط
بشكل كبير في هذه القضيه والنظام السوري
يبدو على انه لا يريد ان ياخذ اي مسؤوليه
وفي هذا الخصوص لان وقف هذا التهريب له
وقع كبير على النظام الناحيه الماليه
والاقتصاديه
واعتقد ان هذا طبعا
الترى بشكل كبير على التقارب الذي حصل
مؤخرا ما بين دول الخليج وسوريا هناك ايضا
سيتاب لما يتهم النظام بانه يمارس سياسه
ابتزاز بمعنى نحن نرعبكم بالكبتاجون هو
مورد دخل كبير لنا اذا اردتم لنا ان نتوقف
فارفعوا عنا العقوبات وخاصه قانون قيصر
بما يسمح لنا بالتنفس
اقتصاديا فهنا يمكن ان نتفاوض هل هل فعلا
هذا هو المعنى الحقيقي لما يجري
نعم نعم هذا صحيح هذه هي الاستراتيجيه وهي
استراتيجيه سخيفه للغايه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لن ترفع العقوبات عن سوريا
مقابل هذا الامر لن يقوم اي طرف بهذا
الامر واتخاذ هذه الخطوه على نظام الاسد
يوقف هذه الشبكات لكن كما نعرف تبعا
للتقارير فهذه الشبكات قريبه من النظام
بما في ذلك اخر الاسد ماهر
هذا مشكل حقيقي وهذا اختبار بالنسبه للاسد
اعتقد ان الاسد فشل فشلا ذريعا في هذا
الاختبار الاردن سيد المعايطه وصل الى حد
القيام بضربات جويه داخل التراب السوري في
الثامن من مايو الماضي كانت هناك ضربات
اردنيه وزير الخارجيه السيد ايمن الصفدي
هدد
بمواصله العمل العسكري اذا استمر التدفق
هذا التهديد او هذه الضربات لم تاتي
بالنتيجه هي شوف لانه موضوع الكبت موضوع
معقد هو زي ما قلت لحضرتك هو ليس فقط في
الجنوب السوري جهه الحدود الاردني وفي
اللاذقيه مثلا على البحر المتوسط في نشاط
ومصانع كمان بشكل كبير احنا بالاردن
الاردن بيحاول يوصل لحل عن طرب عن طريق
احترام لدوله السوريه لذلك هو بيتحدث عن
اجتماعات امنيه بتحدث عن جهد تقوم في
الدوله السوريه لان المساله لها الشقين في
شق من الحدود الاردنيه وداخل الاردن وفي
شق من الحدود السوريه داخل ارض السوريه ما
هو داخل الاراضي الاردنيه هذه مسؤوليه
والاردن يقوم بها لكن هو يطالب سوريا
باداء دورها داخل الاراضي السوريه اليوم
الاردن باله طويل بروح لكل الاجراءات اللي
هي عبر بيان عمان او عن العمل السياسي او
عبر العمل الامني والتنسيق والاجتماعات
لكن في نهايه المطاف الاردن في يعني لن
يسمح بالذهاب بعيدا للسوريين في هذا
الموضوع يعني عفوا وصلت الامور حد اغتيال
بعض المهربين وهنا تفاوتت التفسيرات البعض
يقول النظام هو الذي يختانهم حتى يبعد اي
علاقه هناك من يقول جهات اخرى اغتالتهم
هناك من يقول تصفيه حسابات بين هذه
العصابات يعني حتى الاغتيالات لم توفق لم
توقف هذا عمليه عسكريه والاردن لم يعلن
رسميا انه يعني هو الذي قام بالضربه لكن
الاردن بيعلن تماما انه بيروح لخطوات
ويستطيع ان يذهب خطوات لكن الاردن لا يريد
ان يدخل عسكريا الى الارض السوريه تحت اي
بند على كل حال هذه المساله اليوم تتوسع
كيف موضوع الارهاب في المنطقه والاقليم
خطر على الجميع موضوع الكبتاجون بالنسبه
لنا خصوصيه انه متعلق بان المجتمع الاردني
الاجتماعي ومتعلق ايضا بالتهديدات من
الميليشيات الحرس الثوري بشكل الايرانيه
بشكل مباشر على الاردن لكن الى بعد اقليمي
عام لكن الاردن في نهايه المطاف اذا لم
يجد تجاوب من السوريين كل لليوم النظام
السوري يتحدث بلغه مماطله الرئيس كما قلت
لحضرتك قبل قليل الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
في احدى اللقاءات الرسميه قال والله عنا
فساد وعنا رشوه وعنا فوضى وما مش قادرين
نضبط لكن الحديث هذا غير صحيح يعني دوله
تدعي انها انتصرت في الحرب اللي هي
الجائره وانتصرت على المعارضه وانتصرت على
كل شيء لا تستطيع ان تمنع هذا كلام غير
منطقي اليوم الكبتاجون اقتصاد للدوله
السوريه الكبتاجون الاقتصاد للنظام السوري
وللعائله في النظام السوري العائله
المباشره للرئيس السوري لميليشيات لمؤسسات
في الجيش فهم عمليا مستفيدين وفي وجهه نظر
اخرى كنت سالت حضرتك عنها الاخوان انه في
وجهه نظر عند بعض القوه في سوريا الرسميه
اللي هي بتعتقد ان كل دوله لم تقف مع
النظام السوري خلال العشر سنوات الماضيه
هي تعاق كانها تعاقبه عن طريق عدم ضبط هذه
المساله والسماح يعني تعزيز الفلتان
باتجاه مزيد من التهريب ومزيد من محاولات
الثرية فهي الجزء الاخر انه انتم بالفترات
الماضيه وقفتوا ما كنتم معنا فشوفوا ذوقوا
الان من هذه الحرب يعني نوع من العقوبه
الفلتان جزء منه نوع من العقوبه اللي كانت
اللي تحاول سوريا ان تعاقب فيها او تقول
او تستخدمك عقوبه على بعض الدول العربيه
في هذا الموضوع على كل في اطار هذه الحرب
المتواصله
لمكافحه المخدرات المصنعه وخاصه منها حبوب
الكبتاجون اعلنت واشنطن عن تشكيل تحالف
دولي في السابع من يوليو تموز الماضي يضم
هذا التحالف اكثر من 80 دوله واكثر من 12
منظمه اقليميه ودوليه وقال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن ان تركيز التحالف
سينصب على تطوير سياسات عمليه لمنع صنع
المخدرات والاتجار بها والتحرك بصفه عاجله
حتى لا تتحمل المزيد من تتحمل المزيد من
المجتمعات بجميع انحاء العالم التكاليف
الكارثيه لانتشار هذه المخدرات
وفي مارس اذار الماضي ادرجت وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه شخصيات مقربه من عائله رئيس
النظام السوري بشار الاسد ضمن قائمه
العقوبات على خلفيه دورهم في انتاج وتهريب
الكبتاجون وفي الشهر ذاته قالت السفاره
البريطانيه في لبنان في بيان اصدرته
تعقيبا على قرار الخزانه الامريكيه ان
النظام السوري يستفيد من تجاره مخدر
الكبتاجون بخمسه مليار وسبعه 700 مليون
دولار سنويا واضافت ان نسبه 80% من
امدادات العالم من الكبتاجون تنتج في
سوريا واشار السفاره الى ان النظام السوري
له دور وثيق في هذه التجاره حيث تغادر
شحنات قيمتها مليارات الدولارات من معاقل
النظام مثل ميناء اللاذقيه مثل ما اشار
ضيفنا قبل قليل لافته الى ان ماهر الاسد
شقيق الرئيس بشار الاسد يشرف شخصيا على
تجاره الكبتاج
وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدون قد وقع في
اواخر عام 2022 مشروع قانون لمكافحه انتاج
الكبتاجون وذلك بعدما اقره الكونجرس وينص
مشروع القناه القانون على ان تجاره
المخدرات المرتبطه بنظام الاسد تعتبر
تهديدا امنيا عابرا للحدود ويطالب الوكاله
الامريكيه بوضع استراتيجيه مكتوبه خلال
مده اقصها 180 يوما من تاريخ توقيع هذا
القانون لتعطيل وتفكيك انتاج المخدرات
والتي تجارب بها والشبكات المرتبطه بنظام
الاسد في سوريا والدول المجاوره
ضيفنا في
واشنطن سيد اندرو تابلور هذا التحالف
الدولي بقياده امريكا هل يمكن ان يغير
الاوضاع التي كنا نتحدث عنها قبل قليل
التحالف لا يمكنه القيام بكل شيء لوحده
نحن نعرف ان الاردن يقوم بعمليه عسكريه
وهذه العمليات هي فعاله ضد بعض
المخربين وبعض
اعضاء شبكات التهريب لكن العمل العسكري
وحده ليس كافيا ما نحن بحاجه اليه وايضا
عمل الدبلوماسي وعمل منسق من اجل الضغط
على نظام الاسد لوقف هذا العمل وهذا
التهريب
وينبغي الاستمرار في سياسه العقوبات وبنفس
المطاف التقارب ما بين سوريا ودول الخليج
المشكل هنا ومربط الفرس في هذا الخصوص
التعاطي والتعامل مع النظام الى غايه الان
يبدو على انه فهم من قبل النظام على ليس
عليه ان يغير سياساته
اعتقد انه سيحصل على بعض الاموال التي
تستخدم
للاستثمار في البلد من اجل اعاده الاعمار
وكان هناك فهم بان هذه الاموال ستدفع
مسبقا مقابل تغيير النظام
لسلوكه لكن هذا بعيد عن الواقع العقوبات
ستستمر واذا لم يغير نظام الاسد سلوك فلن
يتغير شيء هو الى جانب التحالف الدولي
سيتابلر هناك ايضا قانون مشروع قانون قدمه
مجموعه من المشرعين من الحزب الديمقراطي
والجمهوري وسمي بقانون اثنين ويفرض مزيد
من العقوبات على النظام السوري
والقانون نفسه يصف الرئيس الاسد بانه زعيم
عصابه دوليه للاتجار بالمخدرات وانه ربما
زعيم مخدرات عابر للحدود
هذه الترسانه من القوانين الامريكيه الى
جانب التحالف الدولي لن يكون لها وقع
حاسم
مشروع القانون المقترح
بالتاكيد
له دور كبير بالنسبه لتعزيز العقوبات
المفروضه على سوريا سيساهم في عزل النظام
السوري وساهم في عقوبات اولئك الذين
ينخرطون في هذه
الافعال
الاجراميه واعتقد ان كلا الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري على هذا الامر
والاسد ليس
بحليب المتحده الامريكيه وهذه الاعمال من
تهريب من قبيل تهريب لا تروق لاي من
الاطراف واعتقد ان هذه العقوبات ستستمر
التحالف الدولي سيد سالم اليامي
لحد الان لا حديث عن تدخل عسكري امريكي او
عمليات عسكريه ولكن المساله الان تقوم على
تبادل معلومات
تعاون امني
بعض المعدات اللوجستيه لمكافحه تهريب
المخدرات هل هذا كافن
من وجهه نظري في الحقيقه ان هذه ربما قد
تكون بدايات لكن لا نستطيع القطع بان مثل
هذه الاعمال سواء كان استمرار في عقوبات
او ضغط على النظام ومحاصره النظام او
تقطيع اوصاله به يعني تفكيك علاقاته ببعض
القوى التي كانت تدعم وتساعد النظام او
جمع معلومات بين الاطراف المتضرره لا
اعتقد انه النتيجه
المرجوه او التي يمكن ان توقف هذا الضرر
انا في تقديري يعني ايقاف هذا الضرر راينا
اعتقد انه الذي اخذ الاردن الى اخر الشوط
واستخدم القوه
المسلحه في رايي ان
الخطوره التي يمثلها وصول المخدرات من
سوريا الى الاردن والى المنطقه العربيه
واليوم هناك حديث بان يصل اوروبا عبر
تركيا وعبر مناطق اخرى في تقديري يعني هو
يحتاج عمل اكثر من هذه العمليه الولايات
المتحده الام قد تكون نصف متحمسه ربما
لهذا الموضوع لانها لا تعاني بشكل كبير
منه لكن هناك دول في الحقيقه خاصه في
المنطقه العربيه متضرره ومتضرره بشكل كبير
تجاوزت عمليه ان يكون هناك يعني تعامل
للقضاء على المخدرات القضاء المخدرات
يحتاج عمل اكيد اما مشابه للعمل الاردني
او
يعني تحرك معين يكون في مواجهه النظام
النظام في الحقيقه يعني بعد هذه الفتره
اثبت انه غير قادر على تقديم ما يمكن ان
يخفف او يمنع استمرار تدفق المخدرات الى
الدول العربيه وهذا في تقديري يعد فشلا
لكل خطوات السابقه هذا يضعنا امام تساؤلات
كثيره يجب ان يكون هناك خطه بديله هذه
الخطه يجب ان تكون فعاله ويجب ان تتخلص من
الاطر الامريكيه التقليديه الطويله المدى
التي يعتمد على العقوبات تعتمد على جمع
المعلومات تعتمد على اتخاذ قرارات تعتمد
على فرض عقوبات جديده كل هذا في تقديري لا
يجدي في الحقيقه خاصه عندما نعرف ان هناك
ذهنيه يا استاذ محمد موجوده في سوريا وفي
كل حقيقه يعني الفعاليات الموجوده في
سوريا سواء كانت معارضات او حتى قوه
موجوده على سوريا هناك مفهوم منتشر منذ
يعني مطلع الحرب في سوريا قبل 11 سنه هذا
المفهوم يقول ان كل شيء في الحرب جائز بما
في ذلك استخدام تهريب المخدرات والسموم
خاصه انه يوفر عمله ضخمه وانتم ذكرتم في
اكثر من تقرير انه انه يوفر اكثر من خمسه
مليار دولار سنويا وهناك تقارير مؤكده
ورصينه تؤكد انه يحقق اكثر من ذلك وهذا
يعني انه يحقق ما لا تحققه التجاره
السوريه او الواردات السوريه الحقيقيه او
القانونيه او النظاميه وال
[موسيقى]
معينه وحافظوا على مصالحهم فيها لكن لم
يدخلوا بالملف السوري بالطريقه اللي زي
الروس زي اي زي دول زي دول اخرى اليوم
بعتقد الموضوع الخطير في الملف المخدرات
انه في مناطق جنوب وشرق سوريا هي بالنسبه
لنا ما يتعلق بالاردن تحديدا او الاردن
والخليج خليني اقول الشرق وجنوب سوريا هي
المناطق اللي فيها المصانع وهي مناطق فيها
شبكات التهريب وفيها نشاط الميليشيات
لتتبع حزب الله وتتبع للحارس الثوري وهذه
قريبه من قاعده التنف اللي هي تتابعه
للقوات الامريكيه اليوم في واضح زي ما حكى
الاستاذ سالم انه التحالف اللي انحكي عنه
هو ببني خطوات للامام بالتعامل مع الموضوع
هسه الخطوات هذه المناطق لما كانت القوات
الروسيه قبل ما تنشغل بحرب اوكرانيا لما
كانت هي المسيطره بالجنوب السوري كان
النشاط اقل من ذلك لانه ما كانت
الميليشيات الايرانيه هي الموجوده على
الحدود مع الاردن كانت روسيا تقوم بدور في
في الموضوع وكانت سيطرتها اقل يعني
كمليشيات ما لها النشاط اليوم الحل بده
يكون بعتقد الاردن بيشتغل عليه مع
الامريكان والاسبوع الماضي كان القياده
يعني قائد القوات المركزي الامريكيه بعمان
وكان في لقاء مع جلاله الملك وفي لقاءات
بعمان وقبله كان في مسؤولين اللي هو
التعامل منطقه شرق وجنوب سوريا التعامل
معها بطرق مختلفه للوصول بما فيها الموضوع
سياسي هسه مرات هذه المناطق بالمناسبه انت
بتشوف الذي كان يجري بالفترات الماضيه
بالسويداء مثلا من عوده من خروج هذه
المناطق على على النظام مطالبتها باسقاط
النظام هذه السويداء مناطق شرق سوريا من
مناطق النشيطه في تصنيع الكبتاجون وشبكات
التهريب هسا حتى الحل السياسي انك تاخدها
تطلع هاي المناطق مسيطره النظام بتطلع
مسيطره ميليشيات ايران ربما يخفف لكن ما
بيحل المشكله بالتاكيد احنا بحاجه لحل
اكثر شمول زي ما قلت لك الاردن بيعتمد على
واضحات واليوم صاروا ثلاث المسار الاول
الجهد مع مع القياده السوريه من باب انه
يعني زي ما نقول احنا بامثالنا الشعبيه
لحق الاعيان لباب الدار يعني نروح معه
لاخر نقطه وتفاوض معه ويحكي معه وتحمل
مسؤوليته رغم انك بتعرف انه بماطل وانه
عنده قناعات ثانيه الامر الثاني ان الاردن
بدافع عن حدوده بنفسه يعني انا لا مش
مستنيين السوريين حلولنا المشكله فالجيش
الاردني من سنوات طويله هو اللي بضبط
الحدود والامن وبيشتغلوا وبيشتغلوا حتى
داخل الاراضي السوريه كمعلومات شي عسكري
والامر الثالث اليوم مع الامريكان بموضوع
التحالف مع دول عديده اللي هي محاوله
التخفيف بس القصه واسعه وزي ما قلت لك
النظام السوري نظام يعتقد انه يبتز هذه
الدول بهذا الموضوع ولسه عنده قناه جزء
منهم وبما فيهم ربما مقربين او رئيس بشار
الاسد انه احنا رجعنا للجامعه العربيه
العرب مش احنا مش احنا اللي كنا محتاجين
نرجع العرب محتاجين نرجعونا فبتعامل
بفوقيه حتى الخطوات اللي العرب بيتعاملوا
فيها بيحاولوا يساعدوا سوريا مش مقتنع انه
العرب بساعدوا سوريا هو بيعتقد انه هذه
ضريبه لانه انتصر في العرب خضعوا له وهذا
المنطق هو اللي بخليه يتصرف احيانا باشياء
بطرق غير صحيحه هو هذا التحالف الدولي سيد
يعني ليس بسيطا يعني تحالف من من ثمانين
دوله من 12
منظمات اقليميه
مختلفه اذا لم يستطع تحالف كهذا ان يفعل
شيئا فهذا بالتاكيد سيحسب نقطه اخرى
اضافيه للنظام في سوريا يضاف على مقاله
ضيفنا الان بالضبط من شعور
بالنشوه بانه في النهايه هو لما يفرض
القواعد الاشتباك مع الجميع سواء اقليميا
او دوليا
نعم هذا صحيح النظام ينظر للوضع على انه
يمكنه من
تاثير على الدول المجاوره وحتى الدول
الاقليميه والدول البعيده لان النظام
يستفيد بشكل كبير من هذا الوضع
وتعتقد ان هذا يعتبر من قبل النظام على
انه هو الصفعه لكل تلك الدول التي دعمت
المعارضه على مدى سنوات لكن ينبغي القول
بان كل هذه الامور تحدث في زمن يريد الاسد
ان يرى الدول الاخرى
تحترم سوريا وتسترجع سوريا الى الحضن
العربي وبنفس الوقت نرى الاسد ونظامه
يستمر في التهريب وفي دعم هذه
الشبكات لكن على نظام الاسد ان يتعامل مع
الموضوع لديه القدره على التغلب على
الموضوع او التقليل منه على الاقل الى حد
كبير لكن قد لا يمكنهم القضاء على كل
مناطق واماكن التصنيع والتحسين لكن هناك
الكثير مما يمكن للنظام ان يقوم به من اجل
القضاء على هذه الشبكات طبعا هذا لن يحدث
في القريب العاجل في تقطيره لكن هذا اذا
ما تم اي اذا ما تعاون الاسد فهذا سيكون
مؤشرا بان الاسد التقط الاشاره ايضا الامر
قد يعتمد على حجم الاموال التي ستضع دول
الخليج على الطاوله ليست لدينا اي معلومات
الى غايه الان في هذا الخصوص لكن هناك
وعوده من السعوديه ومن قبل الدول الاخرى
ومناخرطه في هذا الجهد
ورغم ان التحالف الدولي سيد سالم اليامي
لا يشير الى صيغه عسكريه مالي محاربه هذا
التهريب لكن مع ذلك بعض التقارير
الامريكيه لا تستبعد في فتره من الفترات
قيام الولايات المتحده
مع حلفائها في المنطقه ببعض الضربات
المحدوده على الاقل مراكز تصنيع الكبتاجون
هل تعتقد بان هذا يبقى واردا
حتى وان كان واردا استاذ محمد لا يمكن في
الحقيقه القضاء على هذه المشكله يعني انظر
طال عمرك الى هذه المشكله عندما توصف في
الاعلام وعلى السنه السياسيين في المنطقه
العربيه بانها تهديد الامن القومي وياتي
من يريد سواء كان الامريكان او غيرهم
للتعاطي معها بضربات محدوده هذا في تقدير
يجعل هناك استمرارا لتهديد الامن القومي
هذا منطق الشيء الاخر الله يحفظك
تقارير رصينه ايضا تقول ان معامل السكاكر
والحلويات التي كانت تقدم للاطفال
يعني تم تطويرها او توضيبها او تاهيلها
لكي تنتج المخدرات بمعنى انها منتشره
تقريبا في كل مكان في سوريا وان يعني كل
فصيل او ربما كل قبيله وربما كل مجموعه
بشريه لديها مصنعها الخاصه هذا يجعل
العمليه معقده ويجعل العمليه صعبه
والركون الى عمليات كما يقول التحالف
محدوده
ربما محدوده جدا وفي اضيق النطاق لا تقدم
او تاخر شيء وستكون مثل يعني مرهم على جرح
كبير يصعب معالجته ويريد تدخلا جراحيا
يخفف من الالم او على الاقل يزيل اثاره
المباشره
كالعاده نقوم في نهايه الحلقه بجوله بين
ضيوفنا لنرى لكل ضيف السيناريو والذي يراه
الافضل في القضيه التي نطرحها بالنسبه
لسيناريو ومحاربه نبدا بالسيد سالم اليامي
ثم السيد انظر تبلير وننهي بضيفنا في
الاستوديو السيد سميح المعايطه في ضوء ما
كنا نتحدث فيه الان سيد سالم
ما المطروح عمليا كاسيناريو مستقبلي
لمواجهه هذه الافه
انا في تقدير حقيقه على الاقل من الدول
المتضرره او الاكثر تضررا وهي الدول
العربيه هي جربت مع النظام في سوريا ما
سمي بخطوه خطوه وكان الحديث عن خطوه الى
الامام خطوه الى الامام في تقدير قد يكون
هناك اعتقد انه قد يكون هناك على الاقل
خطوه خطوه لكن الى الخلف بمعنى تراجع عن
ما تم الالتزام به في الفتره الماضيه تجاه
النظام هذا قد يحرك النظام او يغير من
معطياته او على الاقل يضعنا امام صوره
حقيقيه لما يستطيع النظام عمله
اعتقد اننا سنشهد المزيد من الاجراءات
غير مكتمله من قبل النظام محاوله رومانيه
تتبع بعض عناصر هذه الشبكات لكن بنهايه
المطاف الاسد لن يتغير في القريب العاجل
وسيستمر في استخدام هذه العلاقه او هذه
الورقه ضد دول الخليج رغم ان هناك عمليه
التطبيع
وسينجح في ذلك
لا ينجح لكن الامر يتوقف على مجموعه من
العوامل ما هي الاستراتيجيه التي تعتمد في
خضم هذا تقارب الان الحاصل بين نظام
السوري والدول العربيه مساله عوده
اللاجئين والاعمار وما الى ذلك كل هذا
الجزء تتوقف على هذه العناصر
هو
العنصر المهم وهي القضيه التي تشغل الجميع
ولاعتقد ان نظام الاساليب كان يعطي اجابه
شافيه في الوقت حول هذا الموضوع
والله انا ما عندي ثقه انه النظام السوري
راح يكون ايجابي بالتعامل مع الموضوع لانه
بعتقد انه مصدر اقتصاد له واحد اثنين هو
يعتقد انه ورقه سياسيه في التعامل مع
العرب بشكل اساسي زائد الدور الايراني في
الموضوع انه هو ورقه ايرانيه بالاقليم
فلذلك في اكثر من مسار معقده ام تقديري كل
ما استطعنا ان نجعل قضيه داخليه سوريه اذا
استطاعت التحالف والدول انه ينتجوا
كبتاجون كما يشاؤوا لانه بينتجوا في
البيوت يعني وينتجوا بالكميات التي
يريدونها لكن ان تبقى قصه داخليه سوريه
لانه اليوم بالشوارع بسوريا بمناسبه
بيعطيك بتمر بتشتري حبيبه بحكي لها احد
الاشخاص بقول لك خذ لك 10 حبات هديه في
موجود لكن اين يتحول الى قضيه سوريه
داخليه ويتم تحجيم ما امكن عمليه محاولات
التهريب ونقل هذه القصه الى الخارج اذا
استطعنا نوصل لهيك هذا الامر بعسكريا
سياسيا ضروري لكن النفق بنظام انه سيكون
ايجابي بعتقد هذه من الاحلام على الاقل
بالفتره القادمه اذا كان متغلغلا بهذا
الشكل الا يخشى ان يصل في النهايه الامر
الى ما وصل في امريكا اللاتينيه مثلا في
كولومبيا او في غيرها او في المكسيك بمعنى
يصبح جزء من تداخل السياسي بالتهريب بكل
الشبكات الاجتماعيه وبالتالي من الصعب
الشتات وحتى وان كان هناك تحالف دولي او
حتى جديه من دول المنطقه ان يكون المشكله
سوريه هذا موضوع خطورته لكن انه يكون كمان
مشكله عربيه واقليميه كمان هذا اشي مركب
يعني مشكله مركبه لكن بسوريا بعتقد انه
استخدم الكبدهم حتى لتنشيل يعني للمقاتلين
للتنظيمات للجيش موجود منتشر بشكل مخيف
داخل المجتمع السوري وداخل جهه سوريه
ومصدر للتجاره ومصدر للمال لكن انا بقول
الحد من خطورته خارج الحدود السوريه اذا
استطعنا ذلك كاقليم وكتحالف نعتقدنا اخذنا
خطوه لكن استنى انه نظام يكون ايجابي
ويكون يتعمل بعتقد لن يقوم بذلك ولا
يستطيع لان هذه مصدر دخل زائد مصدر ورقه
سياسيه لانه لا راح يروح لحل سياسي ولا
شيء فراح يقايض هاي القصه او جزء منها
باشياء اخرى مثل اعاده الاعمار مثل
مساعدات بشكل او باخر بس القصه معقده جدا
وقد تاخذ مدى اكثر من قصه داعش واراد داعش
كما كانت في سوريا وفي المنطقه شكرا جزيلا
لك سيد سميح المعايطه شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
الرياض سيد سالم اليامي وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا
من واشنطن السيد اندرو تابلو بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد باذن الله
الاسبوع المقبل مع موضوع جديد
وسيناريوهات جديده في امان الله
[موسيقى]